تبعت هذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم التي تتضارب تصاعدا
لاعمده الدخان
وتجدد ايضا للاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم
السريع في ذلك رغم الاعلان عن هدى ايضا
بالاضافه كذلك الى المفاوضات والمحادثات
التي تجري بين طرفي
النزاع الجيش وكذلك
الدعم السريع في جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
اذا هذه هي الصور المباشره
لتجدد الاشتباكات في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
خاصه بان هناك او قد شهدت هذه العاصمه
ربما هدوءا حذرا في هذا اليوم صباح هذا
اليوم
نستمع الان الى دوي انفجارات وكذلك اطلاق
لقذائف
في العاصمه السودانيه واعمده الدخان التي
تتصاعد في سماء الخرطوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات